hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt's ein ganz schnelles eis
rezept ich werde nämlich nutella
eismachen aus nur drei zutaten und ich
zeig dir euch jetzt einfach mal direkt
ich glaube es um schneller anfang hatte
ich noch nie also ich habe hier 200
gramm joghurt zwei sondern drei
schlagsahne und ich brauche natürlich
keine zwei gläser nutella aber etwa 4
esslöffel und ich mach das eis in diesem
förmchen hier und zwar kanada mit eis am
stiel machen die sind jetzt von
tupperware ich hab mir letztes jahr mal
gekauft und damit mache ich jetzt auch
echt oft 1 vor allem auch so fruchteis
also mit saft das zeige euch später das
will nämlich die sanierer zeigen und die
kann so aneinander dran stecken
dann hebt es nämlich auch schön und dann
hat man hier eben diese sticks oder den
deckel dem er dann mit rein steckt und
haben mal eben später als im steht
selbst gemacht und ich mache das jetzt
in einem blender ihr könnt es auch mit
einem handrührgerät kurz machen oder in
einem anderen mixa also das ist völlig
egal
jetzt kommen nämlich einfach alle
zutaten da oben rein dann auch direkt
die sahne
jetzt könnt ihr das ganze natürlich auch
noch aufpimpen mit schokostückchen oder
was auch immer ihr wollt oder
irgendwelche streusel wobei ich finde
dass nutella schon süß genug ist und
eigentlich nichts mehr modelle schmeckt
auch so schon gut und dann noch etwa
vier esslöffel hotel man klar jeder
definierten esslöffel bisserl anders
aber ich nehme jetzt vier figuren
und jetzt wird das einfach nur noch
schnell vermixt als ich auch sehr
schnelle rezept
und jetzt probiert ihr das einfach mal
wenn es euch süß genug ist dann ist es
perfekt wenn ich es gibt einfach noch
ein bisschen tellern
ich glaube die schmeckt so gut ist aber
vom trinken ich glaube ich probier's
doch kurz es kann sein dass der eine ist
größer der andere kleiner aber nur für
mich ist gut ich mag es nicht zu süß und
jetzt fühle ich dass hier in diese
schälchen rein
und dann kommt da jetzt noch der deckel
drauf als er dieser stil
da muss es eigentlich nur noch
eingefroren werden und mit dem kleinen
rest den ich jetzt hier noch ab zeige
ich euch gleich wo ihr das noch rein
fühlen können falls ihr ebensolche
förmchen nicht haft oder ihr könnt jetzt
ganz einfach so kleine döschen benutzen
das sind so kleine döschen auf und zu
bewahren
und da habe ich normalerweise oft
salatdressings drehen oder irgendwas
anderes kleines und da könnte das auch
einführen und dann zeige ich euch den
trick wie man da dann so ein stäbchen
befestigen kann
und entweder stellte die jetzt schon mal
ins gefrierfach und steckt dann so nach
etwa einer stunde ein stäbchen rein weil
wenn ich es jetzt rein steckt und fällt
es der umwelt sich flüssig oder ihr
nehmt etwas alufolie vom ist es
zumindest klappen
laut meiner theorie kontext es damit ab
und wenn man das jetzt durch steckt
müsste es hätten ja
so können das auch machen ist übrigens
stäbchen die habe ich mal ich weiß nicht
mehr wo bekommen aber man könnte zum
beispiel auch so diese cake pops stehle
benutzen
und jetzt kommt das schwierigste denn
jetzt müssen wir die förmchen essen ins
gefrierfach stellen und da drei stunden
etwas stehen lassen könnte auch gerne
über nacht machen und danach haben wir
da unser leckeres 1
fertig und die sanierer das gleich noch
probieren kann man sich das hier einmal
ablösen
das müsste wahrscheinlich kurz mit den
händen so ein bisschen warm machen dann
löst sich das nämlich von der form
können es aber auch einfach unter
fließendem warmen wasser machen dann ein
versuchen halten
hast du deinen zeller 1 deswegen soll es
jetzt gleichauf es bleibt mir hier
schmeckt gut und wenn ihr das nachmachen
wollt könnt ihr einfach auf meinem blog
gehen aufs ellis ließ - einfach alles -
blog.de ich finde sich einfach so ein
superschnelles eismann hat die zutaten
immer da es ist ganz schnell gemacht vor
allem sehr lecker und die samira hat
einfach aus dem schrecken und wir
stecken die jetzt noch auf und papa
haben auch noch ein paar auf und weht
ihnen ganz als auch beim nächsten mal
wieder biss dann kriegt auch 1 und der
rest schritt ich genau im ganzen essen
das fruchteis zu zeigen
deswegen machen wir das eben noch
schnell als ich habe jetzt hier nochmal
61 förmchen und ich nehme da immer ganz
gern einfach einen saft mehr isst am
liebsten in fruchtsaft und zwar gibt es
da auch unterschiede fruchtsaft heißt
dass da einfach 100 prozent fruchtsaft
drin steckt das sind keine
konservierungsstoffe mit drin kein
zusätzlicher zucker außer bei einigen
fruchtsorten weil eben der soll also die
säure da ausgeglichen wird aber wenn er
darauf schaut und steht 100 prozent
fruchtsaft und keinen zucker dann ist es
eben nur 100 prozent frucht und dann
gibt es aber noch andere säfte wie zum
beispiel dieser sauer schmeckt das ist
dann kein reiner saft denn das wird dann
einfach noch aufgegossen mit wasser und
mit zucker und die dritte möglichkeit
die haben wir nie zu hause und zwar sind
es diese fruchtsaftgetränke dass wir
doch oft als so kinder getränke verkauft
da steckt dann vielleicht fünf prozent
frucht mit drin und da rechtlich
eigentlich nur zucker wasser und ich
finde damit das eis zu machen ist hat
ganz cool weil im prinzip können wir so
unser wasser alles selber machen und ich
habe dann halt kein schlechtes gewissen
wenn die samira am tag 23 wassereis ist
weil es einfach fruchtsaft ist und
eben nicht irgendwie zusätzlicher zucker
und von daher und lecker ist auch geld
noch einmal aufhorchen lies einfach den
saft rein und es ist einfach so ein
blitz eis es geht so schnell ok drei
stück so und drei stücke und wie gesagt
bei manchen früchten da muss man halt
zucker mit rein geben oder auch wasser
zusätzlich bananensaft zum beispiel wird
man nie 100 prozent finden weil banane
viel zu wenig flüssigkeit hat und das
muss man immer mit wasser noch mal gerne
trinken multivitaminsaft schmeckt auch
ganz gut
hopp selbst hatte manchmal geklagt wird
jetzt stecken wir einfach noch die
stille rein und dann stellen wir das
auch ins gefrierfach und zeigen euch
gleich ein fertiges eis schmeckt nach
staub
so sieht es fertige eis hits aus geld
und wenn sie es nachmachen wollen wir
müssen sie drauf
abonniert
ramallah
kommentar